you did this I didn't do anything yes
you did start you're listening to the
dollop on the all things comedy Network
way this is a by sickle coastal by
coastal many podcasts each week I lover
of Dave Anthony lover of Dave Anthony
reads a story from American history to
his friend Gareth Reynolds who has no
idea what the topic is going to be about
boom and called it quote is jam-packed
sick arguments
so we are the all things comedy studio
if you want to watch video of this
podcast if you want to watch this go to
the all things comedy YouTube page you
have a dates coming up I already said
this will be the Moontower Comedy
Festival in Austin like April 25th I
believe it is something like that and
then I'll be announcing a bunch more
stuff soon ok and then we will be at
places yeah
North Carolina oh this weekend Carolina
Saturday with me at Durham and then
we'll be Colby Holloway in attendance I
called him Chad last times Colby what
yeah what just happened yeah come on and
then by the way there's a lady with the
young the young daughter she's like four
and she's a fan no but she wanted me to
semi
yeah I think four is a little early to
me damaged
I mean she looks super yeah I remember
she came to the DC show oh yes yeah and
then so we'll be in Columbus on the 30th
and then Brooklyn 18th of May there are
we for sure so that we had a second show
in Brooklyn so when we are in Durham God
hopefully the website is up this week
it's driving me crazy but everything's
almost done and we're just waiting for
legal stuff for Planet change ten but I
would like to have a meeting in Durham
so I don't know I guess I'm reaching out
to you guys send me an email around 5
p.m. I think before the show we'll do
like an hour meeting it would have to be
somewhere
as someone needs to help me find a space
there near the theater or outside of on
message like a Burger King
yeah we're refineries yeah
yeah so so if you guys know of a place
that we can do that and then we'll set
up on how our very first meeting and
I'll kind of try to show how I want this
to run and tape it I guess all right so
that's sexy I think that sexy let's hang
here guess in 2009 2002 in 2000 ago in
2009 two guys set out to make the
perfect tea a tea that felt like an old
favor from day one
perfectly broken in and absurdly soft
those guys were named Mike and Adam it
took them a year to nail a custom fabric
and once they did they made their first
batch of teas and bought an old VW bus
to transport them nine years later a few
credit cards and two buses later they
built the brand in the episode absurdly
soft shirt so talking about marine layer
yeah those shirts are insanely soft and
comfortable yeah it turns out the softs
office tees are made from trees hmm
micro modal found in marine layers
signature fabric is made from recycled
beechwood you know that did you
the pulp production is self-sufficient
wait when I was walking down the street
and everyone's going nice wood that's
what they're talking about that makes a
hell of a lot more sense than what I
thought yeah the pulp production is
self-sufficient which makes their teas
sustainable eco-friendly and you guessed
it soft they make in between sizes like
Marge and larger I would be a lot larger
for dudes who just don't conform to
standards their return policy is
insanely good you can pretty much return
anything for up to a year anything of
theirs or anything in general just say
check out what every way they stand by
their clothes plus they offer free
shipping and free returns on all US
orders I got a nice hoodie that was my
jam I have a nice collared t-shirt so
we've both got looks for different
seasons which is great for us go ahead
for 15% off your first order visit
marine layer comm and enter promo code
dollop at checkout that's marine layer
comm and enter promo code dollop yeah so
do that so it's sustainable shirts yeah
let's get in there it's good listen yeah
say you're a guy and you have hey wait a
minute pal and you have an attorney wait
a minute this has been a minute and
you're is this the guy from earlier your
attorney goes in front of Congress and
just lays the [ __ ] out and really just
makes you look like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
Michael Cohen and what I don't know what
you're talking about
and you got to watch that for hours it's
rough and that's stressful when Michael
Cohen and so between work family and
everything else think you got this going
on it's not easy to find time for
yourself and we all need someone to talk
to especially in the situation where
your lawyer is knocking on you and
there's a person who can support us
through rough patches and you got my
trunk ever know and every every day ups
and downs for life and that's where talk
space comes in talk spaces therapy for
how we live today it's mobile it's
available when you need it and it's
affordable what's it like when you give
your therapist an NDA no matter what
you're going through you're not alone
join more than a million people who feel
happier with talk space it's convenient
it's easy to use you don't have to wait
for your next appointment to talk about
what's on your mind with talk space you
can send unlimited messages for your
dedicated therapist from the privacy of
your device from anywhere at any time of
day if you have enough time like you're
watching TV it's on every channel
it's obvious you can always schedule a
live video session with your therapist
for extra support you can be like hey my
boy my MC he is your MC he is hitting me
dude that's overt like your body blows
I recommend I really recommend therapy
guys especially people who listen to
this podcast talk space has more than
3000 licensed therapists who are
experienced in addressing the challenges
we all face to match with your perfect
therapist for a fraction of the price of
a traditional therapy go to talk space
calm
make sure to use the code dollop to get
$45 off your first month and show your
support for the show that's dollop and
talk space.com mm-hmm always good to
talk there's a there's a box that comes
to your house a box full of good stuff
it's the 2019 fabfitfun spring box it is
on sale now treat yourself with so many
different items it's completely insane
be a hero I'm not gonna be here okay
what a jerk
do do you love discovering new products
I do well then this is the box for you
are you a beauty and fashion maven
constantly on the hunt for the next best
thing I am then this is what this the
fabfitfun box is for you I'm not gonna
bomb or whatever it comes once a month
once a quarter it's a quarterly boxes at
the right phrase it's a seasonal bus
stop talking I have to do the ad talk on
message it's a great great thing trust
me if you're a gentleman and you would
like to give a gift yeah that is really
I recommend my wife loves it when it
comes to how she grabs and she runs away
and you can just toss the stuff in a bag
with some tissue paper and toss the box
in his bag I bought you a bunch of cool
stuff I thought you liked it about a day
away well it's true
I wonder why I'm not in a thriving
relationship I don't know
you give your fabfitfun bucks to Jose is
that correct yes he loves it and he
wears masks he does does he knows masks
a shawl and slippers yeah it's seeing a
cat in a shawl oh it's just delightful
yeah so it's a seasonal box delivered
four times a year with full-size beauty
fashion home fitness and wellness
products for just forty nine ninety-nine
a box full-size products no samples the
spring box total retail value 347 to 350
for yeah I mean yeah there's a lot of
great value obviously a lot of products
individual values more than in the box
right they're killing it great for
discovering new brands and products a
better way to shop talk about fabfitfun
and getting your next one
looking forward to getting your next one
I didn't read that right nope I love you
sign up for fabfitfun today these boxes
always sell out use our code I'll get I
love you use our code use our code dogs
you get $10 off your first box go to
fabfitfun com2 sign up and start getting
the box for life well-lived use promo
code dog to get $10 off your first box
that's over $200 for only $39.99 good if
m fit fun calm and use code doll to get
$10 off your first fabfitfun box great
sorry I love you yeah well I apologize
cool do we're also brought to you by
quip not the word the toothbrush you
didn't say anything I but I will let you
which is more important it is a great
toothbrush yeah I have order new one cuz
I dropped my on the toilet oh man
sound real good with you but it came
really fast look one of the most
important things we do for health every
day is brushing our teeth yet most of us
don't do it properly that was you know
just because of my genetics what does
that mean I'm English quip is better
it's hard to fit around all of them it's
better better is a better electric
toothbrush created by Denison designers
it was designed to make brushing your
teeth more simple affordable and even
enjoyable sensitive sonic vibrations
mean you like that yeah why because
people brush too hard and some electric
toothbrushes are too abrasive it's got
the built-in two-minute timer which
pulses which I love I adore I would say
adore is the right word for sure yeah
your toilet I didn't throw it my toilet
whatever you did it was a dumb night
hold that I pulled it out of the cabinet
flipped out of my hand right under the
toilet sound like it's the brushes oh my
son was watching he and then what you
put your hand in the toilet he was like
what was that I go that was my quip
toothbrush he's like oh you like that
then what did you do did you put your
hand into it no I'm your Hangouts I pull
it out so anyway two-minute timer
multi-use cover you can mount it on your
mirror which I talk about every time
because I love it's my favorite thing
brush heads you can be hot you can get
them automatically delivered delivered
every three months for just five bucks
so
because people leave their toothbrush
for too long I know some people who
throw them in the toilet so that's why I
love quip because I can use it and throw
in the toilet that's why and why they're
backed by over 20,000 dental
professionals there's a lot of dentists
recommending you three that's all of
ours in the toilet clip starts for just
$25 and if you go to get clip comm slash
dollop right now you get your first
refill pack for free with a quip
electric toothbrush that's your first
refill pack free at GE tqu IP comm slash
dollop hey quit waiting so long would
you we podcast what what
don't touch my I don't want to play
footsie while we do it straight to the
camera can see that dude that's just for
us baby good okay come on 1798 ya hear
of our Lord Jesus Christ that's right
he's born the alien Sedition Acts were
past the acts empowered the President to
deport foreigners quote tape dangerous
to peace and safety of the United States
without trial so all of them yeah at
that point made yeah that's a lot in the
opinion of 1798 I mean there were twenty
nineteen I mean there were a lot of
people that arrived you know early so
were were cranial born at that point
right yo ya know we know how yeah we
understand that lasts forever they would
not be kicked out but there's a lot a
lot of people work yeah aliens including
the aliens aliens we are from Spain
started breeding a severely I was ripped
up that's no that's fine okay they
they're it's bad nobody also created a
distinction that could deny non-citizens
the liberties the Constitution
guaranteed to all so that's cool mmm-hmm
during the 1800s Mexicans crossed freely
into the United States for work okay
nobody cared I was like cool
come on over get work yes it should be
yep between 1904 1914 about a million
Mexicans migrated into the United States
okay
only a couple thousand per year were
deported and they were mostly taken from
asylums hospitals and jails okay so the
the crazies the people that are sick and
then and then the criminals I mean the
first two are like cool I am trouble
walking now get out of here move when
World War one started American men went
to fight and then they needed people the
work the fields the places so Mexicans
were brought over so weird interesting
yeah big demand for Mexican labor by the
1920s Mexicans were the main agriculture
workers in the United States okay around
sixty-two thousand workers legally Oh
around a hundred thousand illegally okay
this is pretty sweet yeah yeah but in
Mexico crops rotted in the fields
because all the laborers had left right
okay that's a problem
yeah yeah what do you send who goes
there
who goes to Mexico rises up yeah oh I
don't yeah they just were [ __ ] I mean
okay so cool the 1921 emergency quota
act which you're a big favor fan of and
a favor of and a favor of and the 1924
act were the first truly national
immigration laws though they were built
upon laws from 1800 so in the 1800's I'd
be like let's just get rid of the
Chinese right they'd specifically pick a
like country to be like [ __ ] yeah right
I'm like now and so then these ones they
created like a law to go after every so
like it handled everybody all the
countries now is that better or what is
that like it's worth okay okay much more
everything we do is more harm right I
just wanted to make sure cuz it sounds
like it could be a way to be like no we
are actually you have a focus on some
categories but it's that you matter I've
met we're not great I've been inside us
so these new laws created a quota system
that was overtly intended to establish a
national and ethnic hierarchy you like
ethnic higher what are we for minutes a
arrivals from certain nations were
welcome and people from other nations
were not now how were they defining
these nations well you can probably
guess the ones they liked the ones they
didn't hmm was this based on say skin
after 1924 arrivals from Germany had an
annual quota of over 51,000 well that's
certainly also gonna help you be a
little more open-minded towards other
cultures yeah yeah
Great Britain 34,000 uh-huh Italy had a
quota of less than 4,000 hmm so it's
starting to it's weird because that
there okay no darker skin right that's
sort of what I'm Greece Turkey Syria
only got a hundred hundred people people
okay people people total okay there was
no attempt to hide the white supremacy
of the acts Mexicans could continue to
move freely across the border so Western
Hemisphere everyone's like you can we
can keep coming and out right all good
South Carolina senator Ellison do rant
Smith let me guess
[ __ ] yes ah yes on the Senate floor
quote it seems to me the point as to
this measure is that the time has
arrived when we should shut the door
thank God we have in America perhaps the
largest percentage of any country in the
world of the pure unadulterated
anglo-saxon stock and it is for the
preservation of that splendid stock that
has characterized us that I would make
this not an asylum for all the oppressed
of all the countries but a country to
assimilate and perfect that splendid
type of manhood so he said very
eloquently just why why why why why why
right in 1924 the border patrol was
established okay it was under the
Department of Labor it was focused on
border smuggling for the most part they
also look for Chinese coming through
Mexico
sure then in 1928 people began to focus
on Mexicans coming across the border
okay and what year 1928 okay it was time
to argue to exclude Mexicans right yeah
Texas congressman John box quote boy
here we go
every reason which calls for the
exclusion of the most wretched ignorant
dirty diseased and degraded people of
Europe or Asia demands that the
illiterate unclean Pianist masses moving
this way from Maine iced P&I is ionized
moving this way from Mexico be stopped
at the border P an iced I don't know
what that word means
it's not a word that my my son
understood yeah it's like an old word
that they didn't but essentially the
idea here is just I mean maybe a
stronger definition of the downside of
the non-white which is now they're
getting dirtier and filthier and more
diseased and decrepit and wretched like
before like ten years ago they were fine
but now they're another now yeah well
yeah I mean now but now but again you've
got to understand now America has got
its groove back ya know we know we look
good in white we're assessing ya sassy
and a white little outfit so this is a
new turn for the u.s. i'ma tell neck now
Mexicans had not been villainized he
went on well that's a fun time to harken
back to isn't it what who can who can
remember yeah so he goes on quote oh
good I was gonna say don't stop another
purpose of the immigration laws is the
protection of American a racial stock
from further degradation or change
through mongrelization oh god Jesus
Christ I honestly don't know what's
better the openness or the hiding of it
because now they hide it so much yeah
and it get away with it I mean I I don't
like it when they say it but it's kind
of like wouldn't you rather know yeah
you'd rather know like oh I'm gonna I
hate this person yeah instead of being
like huh he's got weird policies that's
right
there's something associated with all of
them this blend of low
a Spaniard no talking yes this great of
low-grade this blend of low-grade
Spanish no great Spaniard like no those
like the bargain bin of Mexico it's the
lower it's the lower level and as I like
to call him a half Spaniard the bottom
quarter of Spaniard peon eyes dat Indian
and negro slave mixes with mulattos and
other mongrels and some sorry y-yeah hey
can we get that hook to put around his
neck and yank him off the floor and some
sorry whites oh here comes the sand man
[Laughter]
are already here this nation has an
influx of sand men we need to get the
Sandman out they are sweeping people off
stages left and right nobody knows what
we're talking ok the prevention of such
mongrelization and the degradation it
causes is one of the purposes of our
laws which the admission of these people
will tend to defeat the Mexican peons
are illiterate and ignorant hey Bobby
riff a little find it baby find it
you're in you're in the groove in the
zone baby whoa because of their
unsanitary habits and living conditions
it's an hour he's doing and their vices
they are especially subject to small pox
venereal diseases tuberculosis another
dangerous thing well finally a little
truth ya know for sure
STDs definitely racial profile sure a
few if any other immigrants have brought
us so large a proportion of criminals
and poppers as they have makes the
Mexican peons yeah well as usual you
just have to say it and then a bunch of
people will buy it
yeah so look there there they've been
coming for a while right and I get some
photos of Aaron so obviously they come
they're pretty poor mm-hmm yeah mom they
just here to work they they don't have
higher disease loss in other people oh
so that was fabrication oh yeah
interesting
so this narrative that is being said by
politicians starts getting picked up by
prominent writers like Roy Garris or The
Saturday Evening Post America's yeah
where you go for informative debate
who's the guy does the paint the
pictures Bob Ross no oh yeah the classic
Family Circus stuff no Picasso nope
somebody nice someone is screaming at
home and so we're not gonna say it
because that'll even make them crazier
so we just play sure yes I like a
classic American painter guy that does
like these no let's not say it so people
yell at the yellow take part take that's
right oh it's Monet so he so this writer
for Saturday Evening Post he wrote
articles titled we must be on our guard
and the Mexican invasion you know it is
a pretty refined system where
politicians just lie to stoke fear and
then writers give them a microphone
interesting by the way can I show you
something
yeah oh my god what the [ __ ] did you do
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you why
don't you have you saw that Instagram ad
- right I'm a big fan of yours that's
the worst thing anyone's ever done the
Great Depression came okay and then the
Dust Bowl
Mexicans were now the bad guys taking
Americans jobs
yeah so before they're dirty now they're
stealing jobs yeah a push came to deport
Mexicans Herbert Hoover kicked off the
Mexican repatriation program in 1929 so
you've got right you got poor like these
they lived in really I mean it's just a
house made oh like hard yeah
so the repatriation program is over the
next ten years at least half a million
Mexicans and mexican-americans were
deported to Mexico okay
Mexican Americans also okay some say it
was high as two million in 1934 the
Border Patrol switched to smuggling
sort of switch from smuggling to
immigration control so now the brother
patrol getting more longer about labor
now it is about enforcement right so
before as it was set up not this before
it was on the lookout for crime and now
it's on the lookout for Mexicans yeah
now it's now it's law enforcement
righteous good to see the [ __ ] bolts
tighten a little bit in the machine so
here's some guys being repatriated they
were held without food and water for two
days you know I I just more I do miss
the time when this show these stories
were not relevant yeah so that's just
those are all people going through the
bus station or train station to get out
of America right well we'll all be there
soon that's the goodness so the Border
Patrol starts conducting raids city of
Los Angeles and charities paid to send
the repatriate owes back by train
a witness quote they put all the people
in boxcars instead of inside the trains
they were here they were in here legally
but the moral part of it like separation
and putting them in boxcars I'll never
forget for as long as I live up to half
the repatriate owes may have been US
citizens so I mean just doesn't matter
no I so I read that people got kicked
out of the country and then later on
you'll see that we invited them back in
and they came and learned they were US
citizens they didn't even know cuz they
got kicked out when they were kids and
they were never told Wow so they come
back and discover they're actually
Americans so that's like good and awful
music oh great I'm a citizen of a
country that did that [ __ ] this then
came World War two in 1940 the Border
Patrol was transferred to the State
Department and became national security
so it's it's working its way up it yeah
yeah it's working its way a little arch
backed monkey is learning to slowly walk
and point so
World War two happens what happens in
war the Americans good if that's when
the Americans are just hey hey yeah
that's what you boy that's when you take
lloyd doppler's boom box like I'm so
sorry like they think where I was I was
punching you in the face did you know
that I didn't know that yeah I can use
your help oh yeah it's a weed you've a
war now yeah now well you know use your
help
oh that's weird and then is this forever
help or this yeah yeah this forever a
hypothetical situation the war ends you
and I are still cooler bros we're bros
super for life yeah right there's
nothing nothing gonna break us apart the
war ended yesterday get the [ __ ] out of
my country that was a lie to you it's
joke guys do how we're not people gonna
learn that America's just a funky punk
like prank show like what just having a
little fun that's what America needs to
do more point to a camera that's not
there we're goofing okay it's America
hey smile well it's pranked
okay so repaid repatriation ends because
the war is on right Mexican workers come
back to the US but this is hurting
Mexican agriculture again because all
the workers are gone crops start rotting
in the field in Mexico so now Mexico
needs a way to slow the laborers from
moving in to the United States here we
go and the two countries came up with
the Mexican farm labor agreement or the
bracero program ok bracero means manual
labor under the agreement Mexico would
let certain laborers work in the u.s.
short-term in exchange we would tighten
our border security so Mexico would have
enough of laborers to work in their farm
so it's basically letting in an amount
of legal workers and and tightening down
on the illegal workers right that's
that's the idea and but the legal worker
status is temporary yes so if you're
illegal I mean I if your legal worker
essentially it's just kind of like for
lack of a better term you're just trying
to get cash yeah like you're just trying
to make it
and then you probably look a summer job
right so braceros a young single man
okay yeah there's some braceros they got
medical screenings to get it so to get
in you had to get a medical screening
you know pictures like this don't ever
age well it's a bunch of dudes with
their shirts off getting like needles in
them like all right all right you go to
the left of the good Mexicans and then
to the right of the bad Mexican all
right sir sorry you're gonna have to go
to the right go to the right and we've
got a left
you get three months of your dream
living the dream
give us your tired your poor your hungry
till August that's what we say of course
they were you know delouse DDT it's good
for you well anybody who's getting
sprayed with DDT is a short-term worker
no I think that's what's in Gatorade no
no no my friend that's electrolytes oh
my bad
so the photograph strip D last the whole
deal then they're delivered to farms in
the u.s. delivered delivered there the
employee there employees of the US
government so they're it's done through
the government and you like I think rent
them from the government it's a cool
thing anyway it doesn't go well if you
can imagine what part was bad well
surprisingly and the braceros were not
treated well oh yeah I'm sorry I see how
the pictures farmers didn't like all the
paperwork they had to do and the rules
they preferred it when they could just
hire yeah it was here yeah that document
or sure farmers lobby Congress to cut
Border Patrol funding so undocumented
cross right and Mexicans with families
needed work right so the braceros are
all single dudes right so that leaves
out the guys who have a family which is
probably tons of people right you got to
feed your family so those guys had to
come illegally right so named created
this hierarchy right
so unions got mad at that and you got
mad at the braceros in America but and
they and the illegal workers they're all
so mad at or no you unions yeah the
other matter everybody
but they're mad at the government for
doing this right and then rumors start
that in America amongst Americans that
braceros had tons of Rights sometimes
more than Americans sure
super rights yeah it's like the HOV Lane
but when you have one passenger that's
like the classic like just what you hear
the news is they're getting super rise
yeah look they're like do it they vote
five times do you know that they can
vote when they're 15 five times any
state they want they even got to be
resident yeah sounds right what's your
deal you just not a chatterbox honey I
just believe everything you say well
I'll tell you that's the thing you know
when they go shopping they get to times
many they buy back groceries and then
they go here's a duplicate same price
god super rights guide that's what they
get god damn alright god they can marry
as many women as they want hell I seen
one of them he married two goats they
got super rats that's not a yeah marry
two goats that doesn't seem like it I
told him what stands on their backs they
can kiss why would you want to marry one
goat exactly that's what I'm saying
that's why you or two Jews more than one
you twice the fun I don't want to talk
to you twice the goat marriage you can
keep it spicy in the barn room the barn
room
yeah you're talking about the barn yeah
yeah yeah but that's you know where you
sleep
come on these guys are pinging goats I
don't think you know man you ain't read
read up on super rights dumbass what I
read up on super rights well they got a
pitchfork with five prongs yeah that's
two prongs to planting so I'm gonna go
on I'm wrecking and say you don't know
what's better than other stuff you
understand you know they're getting
additional hands attached to their hands
again the super ass this is not
absolutely their kids when they put
their kids in school they're allowed to
teach the white kids imagine that the
whole world's gone tops
turvy this country used to be about
watts now it's about super rats
whoa I think I just invented the bumper
sticker there's no cars Oh
another failed concept so very expensive
for braceros they had to pay bribes to
get into the program sure in Mexico they
depend then they had to pay to travel
there to go to Mexico City first to get
the get tested and then come to the US
and get tested they also couldn't leave
camps and us they're put into camps here
had to pay it's time to change the name
yeah for they'll if they were on a play
post they'd play for company food
lodging and tools and blankets they have
to pay for everything which is all
supposed to be free but right I got
charged braceros started striking one
farmer quote we used to buy our slaves
now we rent them from the government hey
we'll be right back right back after
this I feel uncomfortable
Wow but they're all happy when they're
when they're getting their picture taken
and taken off for work right what was
coming right right in 1948 the braceros
stop being US government employees and
became employees of the farmers okay
then the US opened the border again to
let in undocumented workers because
farms needed more workers which
undermine the agreement with Mexico
completely it's like when someone's like
in a relationship that's wonky and then
like so that's on-again off-again and
when it's off again they're out partying
and just [ __ ] everything but then a
week later they're like I'm engaged see
things have changed I'm stop texting me
yeah
I'm different now yeah so yeah braceros
started leaving their shitty working
visions and going to work on farms which
made technically them now neither Hill
illegally right under the bracero
agreement the US was supposed to return
undocumented workers to Mexico where
they would be given physicals Finnick
fingerprinted photographed and given a
work permit and then returned to the US
wait explain that again they're supposed
to go back to Mexico so
if something if they find it if the u.s.
finds an undocumented worker right oh
right okay then you go back to the
processing department yes you go through
your shirtless line where someone puts a
needle in your arm that's probably dirty
your delouse and then back right okay
and so that exact farm you're on right
right okay see there's a couple guy just
got their permits uh-huh but yeah sure
so what I gotta wear shades
now the undocumented were called
wetbacks because they swam across the
Rio Grande River now wetbacks was a term
used by both friend and foe so it was
just the term for for undocumented
people it's nice to see agreement
finally so people who supported them and
like help them out called them what men
and people who didn't like so it was
just a way to describe them right there
was no derogatory connotation right
people were if you can thankfully if you
could imagine with the term [ __ ] yeah
no no something about that definitely is
not cool but the people who like I mean
yeah but that but that isn't that isn't
that our culture isn't that the white
culture in America one where it's just
like even if you're embracing another
race the bar has been set so low that
really it doesn't really matter what you
say I mean you could say anything you
know through the trip into the US was
dangerous and many died they became easy
prey for criminals they had a difficult
time finding houses some lived in holes
covered with tarps some lived in caves
irrigation ditches or tree groves geez
diseases spread because they wouldn't go
I mean that self-fulfilling yeah if a
person is not is not here legally
they're gonna be afraid to go to the
doctor if you make people sleep in trees
very probably less safe and healthy they
became they got blamed for increases in
crime and yet still no penalties for a
farmer who hired them right well it's
nice we get to have our raises cake and
eat it too
and soon the US was doing what was okay
so undocumented workers so they were
first they were being arrested and then
sent to Mexico to the Mexico City and
there to go through the process and then
get sent back and then we started going
with a shortcut so the shortcut was
you'd arrest an undocumented worker take
him to the border make him put his toes
across the border and then pronounce him
a bracero and bring him back
so basically border suicides it's not
suicide it's no suicides like when you
got to run the lines in gym clothes yeah
yeah we just got across one of them run
back yeah it's yeah so huh I'd mean Dave
think this is normal well I just think
that if that is I mean if that's what
the law is maybe it's a little goofy hey
get out of here you oligo better yeah
it's [ __ ] me so that's getting paper
paperwork done so that's out now it's
just 1949 the vast majority of braceros
had gone through the toe tipping border
ceremony which became called oh boy
drying out the [ __ ] Oh God what's so
way to lean in near times is nope is
nobody going like hey this is crazy
it's all bad New York Times quote the
typical [ __ ] can be described only as
a Mexican and a man but he may be an
illiterate peasant from Chihuahua
resembling with his straw hat serape yes
and sandals one of Pancho Villa's
followers he may be a relatively
sophisticated unemployed industrial
worker from Mexico City the [ __ ]
brings all kinds of contraband with them
from drugs and parrots to venereal
disease first of all the order of your
concern list is bananas yeah parrots
they've got syphilis parrots
zees Mervin sorry yeah this the second
one you said disease the one before that
they've got syphilis parents do that no
that one hate disease yes between
disease and venereal well do you want me
to be small are you asking me to be more
specific with the disease the bird one
you said a baby
you said a bird I'd have a bird disease
no you no you said I got to fire it
burns oh they got the disease diseases
no the parrot that one a parent before
their parents the parents are coming
across with their kids right and the
kids got little baby parents now I do my
valid point parents I mean we are manin
at what point are you like hey this
feels like [ __ ] when people are
creating parrot phobia you gotta be on
the alert for parents because parents
come here and they take your eyes that's
a [ __ ] eye that's right yeah I can't
see but then also the idea that you know
in the new york tyke the it's just with
the media they are it's just never
pinned good never been good never been
helpful never been valid it like never
never you know leaning into the [ __ ]
they're there to escort you along the
[ __ ] path set by the politicians
yeah i mean i might have to do an
episode of venezuela just because of the
insane lives well I think unfortunately
Dave I'm gonna have to push back here a
little bit in the United States our
history of invading other countries to
help name one that's gone poorly like
thank you
they're so so different places are like
they're costing tons of money right
because they're bringing parrots and
venereal disease in that order
mmm-hmm in the 50s everywhere it's got
eight in the Jesus because you imagine a
syphilitic parrot right birds when I
paint rock my beak is falling off in the
50s everyone in the u.s. became
terrified of communism and concluded
that if Mexicans could walk across the
border so could commies it is nicer when
boogeyman is just a belief system versus
a human skin color it's just I mean it's
absolutely dumb as [ __ ] exactly the same
is but it's dumbest [ __ ] but at least
then people like you can't see him
that's the bad thing about communism it
hides under any race headlines Mexico
Center of red spy ring in hemisphere the
nice things they found yeah a connection
so that's right nice brief period of non
[ __ ] cited as aids to mobs and
subversion alien influx perils nation
Senate told by who the parrot the
whether the the commies could come
through the South the alien yeah that's
right so but the the the Border Patrol
was still understaffed underfunded and
had little motivation a Border Patrol
officer complained trying to stop the
influx was quote like trying to bail out
the ocean with a bucket we'll get there
in 1950 the UN accused the UF u UF the
in nineteen ninety bucks the United
[ __ ] the 1950 the UN accused the u.s.
of tolerating slave labor on a wide
scale owners were giving immigrants work
not paying them and then calling the
Border Patrol to deport them well yeah
so I mean I mean all I can say with
after hearing that as a capitalism
sounds great hmm the New York Times
wrote about the immigrants quote
California jobs going to Mexicans in
areas have huge Idol roles the article
said fifty thousand Mexicans were quote
swarming Central California
erat they're coming there in a formation
be liberal their vision is based upon
movement staying still the Secretary of
the El Centro Central Labor Council
quote the wetbacks are infiltrating
nearly all branches of labor union but
they were needed the Imperial Valley
farmers decision Association said only
Mexicans could do the hard farm work in
temperatures over a hundred degrees
these people also just happen to be the
cheapest to pay who could also be easily
abused a farm worker explained that
Mexicans and Filipinos were suited to
farm work and white laborers were quote
too revolutionary in other words what
revolutionary meaning they want to be
done at foreigner wine yeah they wanna
eight-hour day and they want yeah and
the other people are desperate for work
so I can take advantage of them when
asked about all the reports of abuse of
Mexican immigrants a local immigration
chief said quote actually I think our
men give excellent treatment for the
most part they pick up wetbacks baggage
and collect their wages for them I mean
and he's on the side I mean he's in the
role of trying to help no I know he's
immigration like I a nice guy help
anybody there's no help happening okay
good good
the presidential fact-finding shining
Commission on migratory labor was
created it concluded immigrant workers
were controlled and relieved of their
wages through drugs liquor and
prostitution the Commission blamed low
wages and social ills on illegal
immigration quote the magnitude has
reached entirely new levels in the past
seven years it is virtually an invasion
yeah I mean virtually sure I mean if if
you're your version of an invasion is
people coming to work for you yeah like
if virtual means not real like I I like
if you go to Target at 7:00 in the
morning every morning there's an
invasion oh yeah all these people come
in and then nine minutes like a daily
invasion yeah and we should have seen it
coming I mean they called themselves
Target that's right
that's right pretty obvious goddam a
presidential I did that
so a Texas legislature said can we just
start calling them [ __ ]
that's segregation was necessary yes
because kids to get that back in the
verbiage we just can't have all those
dirty possibly diseased people swimming
with our wives and children my god
swimming yeah well if you if you need so
they have waterborne diseases yeah we
the this thought comes off of them in
the water under water polios right look
out
it swims right through your pee hole
that's how to get you the polio is a
little worm when you least expect it
you're swimming goes right up into your
pee hole okay think about it your dick
is a disease straw that's constantly
sucking under there
and they're shooting little polio are
Poon's right up your [ __ ] hole into your
belly so doctor I just wanted a flu shot
oh sorry that is the light on the left
oh this is disease phobia sorry I should
have been clear oh yeah next you all
right now what do you want to be freaked
out about my butthole well let me tell
you something they're coming in there
illegally - idiot what line are you
supposed to be in Oh
flu shot no I'm killing time my wife's
here for therapy that's all I need well
there's no one else in line so you're
not gonna have a little diatribe that's
where I talking you shut up I don't come
in through your pee hole okay gotta go
I've invented a swimmin trunk yeah you
have friends or anything well I had one
think you don't polio works isn't that
when people are throwing the balls
no that's plaughter polio no it's an
Olympic sports not an Olympic sport Oh
polio is when you yeah usually you're a
child my wife let your leg stop she's
taking the house okay
alright go is there anything else you
want to sorry I forgot where I was
smellable place that's absolutely right
oh all right I'll see you Tuesday dr.
Shapiro or just use talk space and you
can reach me that way what in 1951 the
New York Times published a long
five-part series titled the [ __ ]
problem hey New York Times paper of
record he liberal driving liberal paper
of record yeah the premier liberal paper
in the country well acknowledging this
was trafficking trafficking of human
beings this series explained quote it
has lately been realized that the
[ __ ] traffic offers a wide-open
avenue for communist spies to enter the
country I mean first of all at what
point is somebody going to say [ __ ]
is a disgusting term it doesn't happen
to like the 60s yes well no it's trying
and no I think they're like I think it's
starting to happen now I think but the
New York getting close to getting close
to it I yeah I know
everyone's pretty in it it'd be great if
journalists led it's the early 50s sir
ones pretty [ __ ] happy using it there
is no public record of any having been
caught lately but immigration officer
officers acknowledge that every year at
least a handful of European some of them
with communist backgrounds are netted
among the wetbacks and that and in fact
Joseph Stalin might adopt a perfunctory
disguise and walk into the country this
way yep for sure you don't know and Dave
you're laughing and I just I wish you'd
take a little seriously because we all
remember the Stalin Ito's crossing I
mean can we please time these stories
might come in three southern border
please can we can we at least at some
point have a scenario where Stalin has
to pretend to pretend you Tama from
Caracas is a small village simply as a
pumpkin farmer
we are Ella I'm Katherine they make
skinny real small
I raised by one Russian mother whom I
love and she also Mexican and then that
you know your actions getting weird yes
my father's name is a Pepe and he is my
papa
yes we make a living you know you can
drink water out cactus yes I showed my
grandpappy he take me during quinceanera
we go to my niece's kids in Urania it's
a bunch of things of carne asada tacos
it's a weary from in Mexico it's a my
name is Tommy I heard the phrase that we
use here yes of course I'm familiar but
I was a [ __ ] of another country I have
no direct association with madam
obviously have great respect for men you
know anyone who rise to that rank yeah
clearly
would that and men would love to see
America but he will do it legally if he
do it I mean I know Stein old I don't
know but I know starting to be men of
integrity anyway my family is lineages
strong roots in Caracas and that data's
where my family is from here free to
come in so to deal with the problem the
u.s. decided to fly undocumented people
out of the country died idea being that
taking them deeper into Mexico would
make it harder for them to return so
you've been taking just across the
border now they're gonna fly them deeper
in right yeah no that's the problem is
the proximity it's yeah these were known
as the [ __ ] airlifts can I get a
bucket to throw up in a headline from
the monitor quote sixty scared wet wet
sixty scared wetbacks fly first airlift
together all together thirty four
thousand twenty six Mexican workers were
flown to the interior of Mexico
the flights ended after a few months
quote the flights were halted because
officers ran out of wetbacks to deport
god it's just this yeah it's a good time
I mean why even land you know what I
mean just toss him I think that would be
a little that really shake the
foundation of this movement yeah in
march 1952 a new law was passed the i ns
could now search property without a
warrant within 25 miles of the border
well good I mean it's nice to see you
know intelligent policy finally rising
to the top anyone helping undocumented
immigrants would be charged with a
felony but employing them was fine and
not a crime boy you really really really
really wonder what the [ __ ] the plan is
don't you
well it's just so like it's just some
[ __ ] insanely transparent yeah I mean
but it's it's yeah I mean you're just
like if you if you if you put them up in
your house then you get a felony but if
you give them work yeah and then they
you're fine no honey it's like I said
when I'm at home we're married and
anytime I leave I do whatever the hell I
want no cuz I took a vow yeah yeah I owe
that June 1952 more legislation the
evening monitor quote President Truman
has placed his stamp of approval on a
[ __ ] concentration camp for the
valley okay well let's just if that
headline stopped let's stop cuz what
just happened when he signed legislation
authoring the Justice Department to buy
land and construct buildings to house
aliens awaiting deportation yeah air
lifts started again the evening monitor
quote when when Truman did it where the
parents allowed to be around the
children ya know they kept and they
tried to keep him they tried to keep
families together so they made an
attempt to keep families together so our
policy usually I think more sense may be
the evening monitor quote the circus
hasn't come to the valley yet this
summer but operations squander the air
back lift sorry the [ __ ] lift the
[ __ ]
is already with us and it may be more
entertaining than three rings under the
big top well there was talk in the Upper
Valley Saturday of organizing a bus and
private automobile motorcade for a trip
to Brownsville to permit taxpayers to
see firsthand the operation of the
Immigration Services deportation by air
of Mexican farm laborers my god
just soulless hey honey uh so this
weekend I was thinking be good I don't
watch a bunch of Mexicans get deported
on airplanes that'd be nice I'll make
sandwiches let's make a day the carnival
is always fun I've been on every one of
those to watch let's watch people suffer
and get on a plane well I mean and you
say it but the reason why it's okay is
because we will never suffer so we have
no realm of comparison or understanding
compassion was drained from us when we
decided skin color was a determination
that's right that's right so turned on
by what we're gonna do Saturday
let's get clams before it lets get all
clammed up and then let's go watch them
suffer it'll be great
begin because there's no way it'll
happen to us because we came here and
took everything the Morning Star
newspaper held a contest you find quote
the most fitting names for the wetbacks
to lift know what have a contest gotta
have a contest my man what are you what
it's what is your problem it's the
ripple effect is my problem
quote today's last day to send in names
to the valley morning star races hurry
get moving now will come the job of
going through the huge piles of cards
and letters to select the winners mmm
that's right it's gonna be a real dimple
or Chad situation when it comes to these
the winner they picked operation outrage
yeah
which the paper only use from that on
that was their new
for cool in Mexico there was less
excitement on what grounds were they
having as much fun the newspaper Nevadas
said Texas had a concentration camp
quote which yields nothing to the Nazi
prisoner of war camps in the way of
Cruelty baseness and inhumanity a
Mexican reporter visited the camp it was
surrounded by barbed wire and patrolled
by Texas Rangers quote our fellow
countrymen packed like cattle lie on the
ground in the open air exposed to the
burning rays of the Sun by day and
torrential rains by night he said there
were wetbacks and braceros whose
contacts had expired quote whippings
clubbing x' and other punishment are the
rule for those who protest in June 1952
construction of camps and airlift
stopped when Congress did not renew
funding so the Border Patrol began
shipping people out by train 2,000 per
week so that's good right yeah it's
super chill and cool and good and fine
cool and chill so the rhetoric continues
1953 the I ns commissioners said there
was a quote human tide of wetbacks God
he said they came and then told their
family members to come because
everything was so great here ya know for
sure
sounds like the Americans are strong
you'd want to stay in their little
village an Assistant Commissioner of the
Border Patrol called this quote the
greatest peacetime invasion ever
complacently suffered by any country how
is it how is the marketing still working
if you use the word invasion yeah for
immigrants coming here you're a racist
and who are who are essential to the
farming community and so if you want to
have capitalism you can't have it
without quote illegally I mean really
how does it get away with it
it is just like greed just is able to
suck up anything it wants and [ __ ] out
what it does because nobody cares well
that's fun I mean the left cares but
nobody else cares like the super left
cares but liberals are fine with the
system that yeah generally for sure or
else they would be throwing fits right
you'd be like no pay them better and
treat them back well it's what happens
when the left shifts to the center which
is far right so the US Attorney General
quote an uncontrolled wave of crime
remindful of the Prohibition era is
sweeping the southwest in the wake of
the illegal entry of hundreds of
thousands of alien Mexicans across the
border so they're whipping everyone up
again right so April 1953 trains and
planes gave way to a new plan called the
quote hot foot lift
mmm-hmm the idea here was to take
deported people 15 miles south of the
border into Mexico into an isolated
desert spot that was deliberately
selected because they would have to walk
a long distance in over a hundred 120
degree heat they had not they were they
had their food taken away there isn't
washing that even with all that the
farmers are dependent on white people
are still the best at picking cherries
their food taken away they had their
water taken away
shelter sometimes clothing the LA Times
called it a death march it was designed
to be so to make them terrified to
return sound familiar
some reporters tried to follow but could
only make it one mile before they had to
stop one reporter said it was it was
like being burned through his clothes
that's how hot it was in 1953 after
another study reported undocumented
workers were driving up costs of police
hospitals and other other social
services President Eisenhower's Attorney
General toward California and then
pushed Congress to
tracked down the Billings Gazette quote
President Eisenhower authorized Attorney
General Herbert Brownell jr. to use all
resources of the federal government to
stem the ever-increasing tide of
wetbacks entering this country illegally
from Mexico California Governor Pat
Brown a Democrat said undocumented
Mexican immigrants brought murder
prostitution and robbery and a quote
gigantic narcotics infiltration he
called them a malignant growth that's
the Democrat super cool liberal
Eisenhower what's right right what is
right on there and this is when
Democrats were farming I know yeah no
they were actually left
Eisenhower's Attorney General Herbert
Brownell jr. had some ideas oh good I
was just gonna say let's hear more from
this guy he asked the army to do mass
roundups of undocumented workers but
they passed because they're not allowed
to do that for a constitution thing well
it wasn't a national emergency at the
tax right and then he pushed for the
Defense Department to pay ten million
dollars to build a hundred and fifty
mile fence along the border to which
they said no okay at an International
labor meeting Brunel said quote one
method of discouraging wetbacks would be
to allow the Border Patrol to shoot some
of them ya know and that finally like I
was just waiting for some reasonable
policy that's right now now we're
getting to a place where we can actually
have a conversation
now we met in the middle Anders look
we've learned from our mistakes and
we're now starting to put out some
rational thoughts without a little bit
of a selected murder and he's just sorry
you know did I mention this guy's the
Attorney General of the United States of
America oh that's why it's valid the eye
an Asst commissioner was joseph jumpin
Joe swing let me guess [ __ ]
ex-general he was a quote professional
longtime mexican hater he had fought
against Pancho Villa as a young man as a
retired Army General
he brought military organization to the
Border Patrol which it really needed
that's what the Border Patrol really
needed was military organist
swing thought his mission was a quote
direct attack upon the hordes of aliens
facing us across the border
hordes of aliens yep Twilight Zone
realities
Harlan B Carter was promoted by swing to
director of field operations Carter had
joined the Border Patrol in 1936 three
years after he was released from prison
for committing a murder
Carter told I mean people are like it
was worse it was better than no it was
no yeah change that it wasn't Carter
told the Los Angeles Times quote it's
the playbook and army yeah it is
actually the book Carter told the Los
Angeles Times quote an army of Border
Patrol officers complete with jeeps
trucks and even aircraft would wage an
all-out war to hurl Mexican wetbacks
into Mexico hurls a clueless yeah let
him end the catapult yeah that's right
so Brunell Carter Brownell Carter and
swing would lead the government's new
immigration operation good it's time for
them to get in charge on June 10 1954
swing announced that operation [ __ ]
would begin on June 17th
so the Saturday evening monitor was like
oh why didn't you enter our contest
we just had an amazing competition you
could have won an umbrella so operation
[ __ ] was to be a mass deportation
event but it was mostly for show it was
a PR move and the media went for it and
hyped it up hey I'm gonna go drown
myself in a pond see employers were
warned to fire undocumented immigrants
and hire busting arrows instead
meanwhile the Mexican so that program is
still going on the bar scenario program
where you bring them over and hire them
and all that
meanwhile the Mexican government didn't
understand why this was being done the u
p quote Mexican officials Friday
expressed bewilderment for us plans to
deport through El Paso Texas and Juarez
they explained they would have to return
them to their hometown so sending them
through specific areas just put more of
a burden on the Mexican government but
again I'm
not two shits given yeah no no this is
America we throw our peanut shells on
the ground at every bar the Border
Patrol was not actually a very large
force at the time it was so so on the
first night of operation [ __ ] Carter
had agents drive vehicles oh yeah still
not getting more comfortable with the
operation title sort of yeah it had it
had an official title that was different
but the IAS used this and so did all the
press so why the [ __ ] would I use the
traditional time well I mean we still
are using [ __ ] in this time so it's
sort of like let's you know get our
ducks in a row so Carter had agents
drive vehicles repeatedly through
McAllen Texas all night so it appeared a
huge group of Border Patrol or arriving
so they were just [ __ ] doing circles
like they were all arriving all night
long but the actual number was small the
raids began on the first day raid
started at 7:00 a.m. they hit street
corners factories brick yards industrial
plants in private homes and roadblocks
all over California Western Arizona 500
people were arrested in Los Angeles
Times headline it says five to Bael a
[ __ ] Raiders Wow yeah so that's cool
it's cool the Raiders are back in
Illinois the Border Patrol was helped by
the Sheriff's Office the LAPD the
California Highway Patrol and the State
Department of Employment buses were
stationed around city jails and when
full they would then take them take
people to camps
so the buses waited and then when they
got full of people they've taken the
camps and then new buses would arrive
empty Greyhound buses the Border Patrol
knew that they were being watched by the
media and we're on their best behavior
mm-hmm they were embedded journalists
were embedded with the Border Patrol so
they became chummy with them and the
reporters read about how awesome and
professional the border patrol were
these papers ran stories with photos of
Border Patrol agents in spiffy uniforms
they looked at maps while planning
operations yeah so look and by the way
if you got a cool photo who cares about
the reality just yeah exactly you know
oh man that's just dynamite couple of
Border Patrol guys we're sure what are
we here about al-qaeda pointed the back
of some way nice isn't it there's
another another one like some guys know
he got in a boat crossing the Rio Grande
and they've just got him with the guns
on them this is a photo shoot it's a
photo shoot yeah it's like a Vanity Fair
photo shoot that's why they brought the
press so that they would get these shots
that would look awesome on newspaper
yeah but there's just a part of you that
I mean it's just like to embers left in
the fire where you're like maybe the
media would say no photo-op of this
nature Californians cooperated everyone
was on board
Los Angeles please quote rendered
assistance far in excess of what could
be expected
isn't it amazing to that in California
like people do consider them set like
there is a an air of superiority when it
comes to understanding and compassion
and yet the reality is California is
just in the bag as everywhere else I'm
just ready and willing to be a fear
mongering hate state just like
everywhere else that's right
so I Anna's phones were overwhelmed as
the American public turned snitch in
masse I think we I mean I'm not sure if
he's won but I'm like 90% California
newspapers referred positively on the
rage Los Angeles Times quote an army of
border patrolmen complete with jeeps
trucks and seven aircraft we'll begin
moving into El Centro today dispersing
their forces for an all-out war to hurl
tens of thousands of Mexican wetbacks
back into Mexico
we are liberal Hollywood get um out a
wire fence security camp to hold a
hundred men was built Elysian Park the
one near Elysian Park so that's that
those guys are in Elysian Park that's
where we drive by often it looks like
it's in a parking lot I know it's an ass
I don't anyway that's nice it's actually
better than some of the other ones
papers also rent photos of workers held
and crude holding pens set up in parks
this one's a little brutal to look at so
that is that just looks like holy [ __ ]
men have been corralled into like a
cattle sort of pen and there's hundreds
of them was there ever like a group
called PIPA so some some men in towns
that were captured were they would be
marched through the town as a big show
again this is all for the press so they
were well and it's it's also it is for
the press for sure but also if you are
anywhere near that that you know you
would you'd be like oh that's reality
there's a show of my god the enemy look
at the amount well so so this picture we
look at this picture and there's maybe a
hundred and fifty men being marched this
town and it looks like four in a row
four and but the pictures taken from
above so this is staged
so this photographer right right onto
the top of the building and then and
they told them they were gonna march by
I mean that's clearly what's happening
you know what we really need to do is
create camps for journalists don't now
you sound like Trump I mean okay for
politicians to in movie theaters they
the newsreels you know showed Mexican
immigrants being rounded up and standing
in the hot Sun while being searched
everyone loved it everyone's like this
is [ __ ] great I'm so excited with the
people behind it even farmers in
California supported the operation and
then phase two of operation operation
[ __ ] started on July 15th in Texas Oh
God
but Texas was not like California their
farmers were openly opposed to operation
[ __ ] okay the government and police
in Texas did not help the Border Patrol
or the
yes yeah but on the first day 4,800 men
were still rounded up planes would fly
low over farms to look for workers I
mean that just the headlines on that
paper are just like it's patrol deploys
by hundreds today's total expected to
reach 3,000 and then below that 12
wetbacks escaped and mass jailbreak in
mass jail 12 mass and I mean there and
they also had photos of them in jails
you know so clearly the reporters are
being led into pictures of in jail which
i think is not cool
so planes are planes are flying over
farms to basically spot workers then
they would radio the Border Patrol who
would then drive to the farm and jeeps
and then the braceros would show them
their papers and they get a stay in the
undocumented be arrests undocumented
guys to be arrested
farmers would get upset quote were being
driven to the poorhouse how do you
expect us to get our crop in sorry it's
just not part of God's plan they were
loaded on try mean it's just like okay
they were loaded on trains and sent back
along the route so they're put on trains
and they're driving on these drive and
they're on these trains and along the
side the trains are bilingual billboards
that read no notice the United States
needs legal farm workers the mayor of
your town can arrange for your
contracting dude warning the era of the
[ __ ] and the wire cutter has ended
from this day forward any person found
in the United States illegally would be
punished by imprisonment so as they're
as they're leaving they're seeing signs
being advertised - yeah
telling them I have a sign up for this
program right this was because operation
[ __ ] was not to reduce immigration it
was to move the undocumented into the
bracero program I mean
there's and they were often just dried
out in which we know what that means
mm-hmm the number of workers on bracero
contracts doubled okay
farmers started picking which
undocumented worker would be deported
and then that work it would be brought
right back
the i ns did not plan for families they
encouraged women and children to leave
voluntarily mm-hmm
this caused men to be separated from
their wives and kids because the men
were being deported of the women in kids
having told the leaves so the women and
kids would go through Mexicali Tijuana
and they would not while the men we put
through a passable Juarez
so there are splitting up families
Alvira Velazquez and her ten-year-old
daughter were stopped on the street and
deported but she had three children at
home the next day neighbors heard the
kids crying she's good kids were then
taken and passed around from neighbor to
neighbor until immigrations learned of
what happened and said they were trying
to find the mother in Mexico uh-huh yeah
what like ya mean that's right Raul
Mendez as a second grader who came to
school the unsigned slips that his
mother was supposed to have signed when
asked why she didn't sign he said quote
Mama's gone she couldn't sign it not
coming back Border Patrol took her by
second grade he had been living alone
for 15 days Wow Border Patrol denied
knowing anything about his mother yeah
of course yeah yeah and that's basically
I mean that's and until I mean you know
until we really just collectively lose
our [ __ ] the argument ends there that's
they put they nub it out it's done well
we it was around here somewhere
I mean it's like it's not you're not
looking for a remote in an apartment I
am we think we've maybe saw a tiny that
sure it's also that kid is seven could
you imagine a seven-year-old living
for 15 first of all kids back then had a
much harsher life yeah at least compared
to the I mean they still do in other
parts of the world but at least in
America for the most part you got it got
a pretty good obviously a shitload of
poverty and starving but but a kid
living being able to sustain himself for
15 days alone is [ __ ] amazing yeah
amazing to me but I mean the truth is
that and this is what will be the real
[ __ ] is when white people in America
or Americans need to get out of this
[ __ ] and what are the other
country's policies gonna feed I mean
what like the abysmal track record no no
they're gonna love us well sink its
teeth so deep into that mass of this
policy we're great Venezuela is waiting
for tons of us to come yeah oh and we're
ready to do any labor but by the way we
need an hour lunch we want to start at
9:00 we want free health care done by
4:00 and we want rides to and from plus
Saturday Sunday and holidays so to save
money
Harlen Carter had Border Patrol officers
charge each worker $10 as long as they
had at least 13 because they could not
be left with less than three that would
be bad if they less than three
newspapers got reports that they were
taking money from workers as they were
loaded on buses the ion has tried to
claim they had the authority to make
quote illegal aliens pay for their fares
but people didn't buy it and Carter was
told to stop hey they'll pay for it but
why he yeah will build a wall they'll
pay for officers in Texas in California
created quote a little barber shop for
chronic offenders at detention centers
this meant they were shaving the heads
of workers so they would be easily
recognizable if they tried to come back
some guys are coming like a lot of these
guys the reason like in some of these
pictures I was looking at you when
they're being arrested you see some of
them smiling because they're like I'll
be back in a week like so but now you
know how do you solve that will you
shave their heads
sure no more sensible policy yeah
in news photos you would see
well-treated Mexicans in reality they
were having their heads shaved and being
dropped in the middle of nowhere
eventually the chief patrol inspector
deemed head-shaving a violation of the
workers civil rights so the Border
Patrol had the Mexicans get a clipping
instead mm-hmm
we'll give it a mullets now in Texas
like I said they did not like operation
[ __ ] and they started [ __ ] with
the Border Patrol one border patrolmen
was ticketed and fined for making quote
an improper start from a parked position
what he just got in his car and started
driving in the and the cop was like [ __ ]
you yeah ticket they were told they'd be
charged extra to cash checks in a bank a
restaurant posted a sign quote dogs and
border patrolmen not allowed some hotels
would rent some hotels wouldn't rent
rooms to Border Patrol officers officers
complain their wives were being insulted
by neighbors and their children were
snuffed by playmates this is the right
Texas right thing yeah yeah yeah Texas
might have a misplace the spine at times
but has one phase three of operation
[ __ ] started in July in Utah Nevada
days three in Idaho there are also
mobile units in Spokane Chicago Kansas
City and st. Louis phase four moved into
the Midwest because this was so
successful Congress gave the ironists
another three million to buy twenty four
vehicles and three planes on March 18th
1954 the inaugural flight of the Border
Patrol Air Transport arm flew 50
Mexicans from Chicago to Brownsville
Texas in its first year the plane flew
11,000 459 workers to the Mexican border
for deportation
they were often sent to unfamiliar
places and not able to take their
belongings that they had in the US once
they were there many had no way to
contact their families they ended up
stranded without food or employment when
they were released in Mexico they had to
get a job to earn money to get back home
or to just support their family so
basically they were just being sent into
a nightmare which I mean if you'd if we
did one on the current situation yeah
very similar
than worse in February 1955 the Mexican
paper Noah dot us again reported
horrific conditions at a concentration
camp near McAllen now being robbed of
their property eight hundred men were
being held in a quote hellish
concentration camp living semi-nude in
misery hunger and sickness what is that
something heaven a camp you mean a
concentration camp of basically naked
people being hunger in sickness what is
that it's interesting it sounds like a
place in what yours this Germany yeah
well it's 1955 well see there was
nothing to replicate around that time
you didn't have there was no recent
memory of any plan of that nature yeah
senator is cool though yeah Democratic
senator not all Nazis weren't armed baby
that's right
Democratic senator Thomas H a coach'll
became upset because he learned the
border patrol was using quote killer
dogs to patrol the border swing general
swing said they owned dogs quote but
they were not the blood for the thirsty
variety no no these are golden
retrievers a good dog they're trying to
fetch arms watch this good dog
C historian I love jowls historian may
and guy said one incident in one
incident quote some eighty eight
braceros diet of sunstroke as a result
of a roundup that had taken place 112
degree heat and more would have died had
the Red Cross not intervened and I'm
sure a ton died yeah come on that's what
you know about you know in 1955 we've
never been good with death no now we're
not that's zero it's not just here in
1955 the Border Patrol announced they
had removed more than a million people
from the country
attorney general Brown al testified to
the Senate that quote operation [ __ ]
stemmed an actual invasion by illegal
entrants from Mexico Swain declared that
the border had been secured but the
million deportation number was [ __ ]
many were counted multiple times some
were counted multiple times in a single
day but shouldn't they just have a
haircut to distinguish them yeah you'd
think so yeah
some are also count
as deported but they had not even been
questioned some people were seen just
crossing the border and were counted as
voluntary departures so basically our
calculations are when you try to guess
how many jelly beans are in a job it's
very much 900 yeah the actual number is
anywhere from 250,000 to 800,000
probably on the lower side that doesn't
even include those who were brought back
as braceros nevertheless newspapers
touted operation went back a huge
success
hey listen whatever gets the propaganda
going right the Eagle newspaper claimed
it was the operation operation was a
success because there were so fewer
deportations the next year that's clear
that's some serious the Eagle newspapers
always been really good I mean yeah
that's right it's the editor yes that
just means they weren't deporting people
not that there were didn't yeah you know
how do you know how did you think well
it's just it's a little wrinkle gleaming
the cube of reality and of course they
said there was a huge drop in crime but
still swing announced plans for a quote
nationwide investigative search program
to flush out thousands of deportable
aliens that were still in the US sequel
baby sequel summer blockbuster the new
Republican governor in California said
all the deportations led to a savings
and unemployment benefits of three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars Hey
look if the price is right
worth it price is right labor
representative Milton plumb went to the
border after operation [ __ ] ended the
operation was had succeeded in creating
anti us feelings amongst Mexicans and
mexican-americans now see that's rude
that is that that's when you go okay
well there's no here oh yeah because for
some reason this animosity come on
get over it I don't know where it came
from get over it you're just trying to
help you can't you can't build a
concentration camp in America and get
away with it come on guy the Border
Patrol was now militarized and
dehumanized the operation had led to an
increase in fake tour cards entry pair
it's forged passports and phony birth
certificate so now because a lot of
Americans got deported because they
would get stopped on the street and
they'd be like let me see your papers
and they chomo Social Security card and
they'd be like no where's your birth
certificate and they'd be like what I
don't carry it on me and then they just
deport him no that's cool the boat they
were boat lifts also so while they were
doing the trains and the planes they
were also doing boats down to Veracruz
the boats were really brutal the boat
lifts continued after the end of
operation [ __ ] in 1956 Reppert
representative robert mola Han said the
Mercurio ship resembled an ancient penal
ship and it had been nicknamed hell ship
that's it but I mean who knows if that's
an indicator yeah
Mahan said the ship would normally carry
70 to 90 people but it had been carrying
500 deported men and that it only had
two lifeboats with a capacity of 48 well
to be fair I mean in your if your
reality is that you don't care about the
life of these people what's the point
that's right well swing testified in
front of a House committee and said a
ship like the Mercurio quote discourages
the [ __ ] from coming into the United
States no risking back another trip on
the boat ok so these these quotes are
exactly what we're doing now yeah
discouraging by making people's life
horvath right trying to yeah proving a
point by saying hey you're breaking the
law
therefore Humanity is off-limits to us
yeah the I&S then made a public show of
inspecting the Mercurio the day after
the ship passed inspection 36 men jumped
overboard in protest and five drowned
the bracero program was ended in 1964
but that did not mean Americans were
hired for the jobs of working in the
fields right farms make mechanized
undocumented workers like the rest of
the American workforce began shifting
from farms to cities under Bill Clinton
thousand people are deported under
George Bush that number rose to about 2
million people deported under Barack
Obama 3.2 million people are deported
hey Obama deported more people than any
president in history these numbers oh
the liberal dialing oh boy yeah yeah
yeah but yeah I know oh dude yeah let's
hope that's all them when they go back
I'll get to go back and do hope stuff
hope these numbers do not I'm okay if
people who were self to Pope I know yeah
that poster yep posters yeah that guy
yeah I know they said that it's hard he
would be the guy that I know but he's
Obama I know but he can't do that stuff
I know cuz he's Batman these numbers do
not include people who were self
deported or who were turned away and OH
returned to their home at the border by
US Customs and Border Protection the
administration focused on preventing
families from sending their children
unaccompanied on a dangerous track by
emphasizing they would be returned
because Obama had faced a new problem
unaccompanied children were fleeing the
violence in Central America their
parents were like you're knocking mail
to survive here and just putting them on
trains and sending them to America so in
2014 the administration started a five
million dollar campaign to discourage
those children from coming so we are in
the country from he began to tanning
most families apprehended at the border
the deportation court processes were
speeded up but many children were
apprehended and held for a long time
Trump put Obama's process on steroids
while Obama saw an increase in
immigration Trump actually saw normal
level but he responded like it was an
insane level concentration camps are
back children are separated from their
parents on purpose and his standard
practice some are never gonna see their
parents again let's correct that a lot
are never gonna see their parents again
they are being given drugs thousands
have been sexually assaulted by guards
at concentration camps almost all of
what Obama has done was modeled after
previous presidents especially
eisenhower
and Obama Trump yeah yeah he took he
took a combination of Obama and eyes
well there's the create what he did yeah
the two things are the there is this
inability for the white to like the
white to process the you know luxury of
privilege yeah therefore you don't why
why people are don't like to hear that
they won't do every job or what like
there's like you know there because this
country is founded upon that there still
is it's like in the bones you know so
the fact of the matter is that if these
jobs will not get done and if it's about
farm productivity then the farmers
should be able to decide what the [ __ ]
they're the policy is the second is the
way that you said the way that the
workforce is when people are deported
it's because of mechanization like
that's the other thing the idea that
you're like you can keep creating
boogeymen to solve the problem but the
reality is that like the economy because
of the capitalist [ __ ] is going to go
the cheapest way possible right and when
the cheapest way becomes machines these
these aren't like fight a war on the
color silver like that's the color the
machines the machines are the ones well
I want them all silver you know but that
is like that's truly like so I mean the
the it's it's such a it's such a
short-sighted propagandist package
because it's like it's it's not at this
point you should not be fearing anything
other than machines I mean yeah I've
always been afraid of machines robots
are gonna yeah your side a side episode
of black mare right with a dog every
time people post a video of those Boston
mechanics robots I'm like okay now
picture with a gun yeah cuz it's gonna
have a gun on it they're not doing that
so a dog a dog robot could open a door
they're doing it so they're gonna be
[ __ ] army
running a ruling by the way these
machines are gonna have all this footage
of when we used to laugh out of his dumb
robot he can't move that shelf that
dummy they're gonna look back at that be
like remember [ __ ] well we were just
but but there is like that so and the
thing that drives me crazy is that
people act like Oh bah sorry Trump is
this aberration and like I can't believe
this and this and this and it's all been
done before or close to it and they're
like we lied and it's like yeah
everybody lies all the presidents like
now he's just doing it in a way that
that's completely obvious and and and
the the Russia stuff I just keep going
okay but all these other countries Saudi
Arabia and Israel get to buy whatever
they want what's I don't know it's so
Saudi Arabia is better than Russia Saudi
Arabia blew up our the twin towers like
what the [ __ ] it's also money crazy
money if I mean and like you're saying
but with trumpet I mean diff different
puppets same hand up its ass yeah it's
just that that's all it is
I mean and the more that truly the more
that you buy into the the show the more
the more insane you're going that and
actually be and then there is so
everyone's like everyone's like upset
about what's happening at the border as
you should be but they weren't upset
when Obama was no well and and that's
what immigration people keep saying
they're like well this like it's on its
worse now but but it was really bad
under Obama yeah like they were kids
were coming like kids were coming from
like [ __ ] Guatemala or El Salvador
which are just we have exported our
gangs and destroyed these countries and
now they're they're trying to take young
kids into the gangs or make them do
stuff so the parents are sending them
away because they don't have a choice
the kids ride on the top of a [ __ ]
train they get to America and then they
either get locked up or they get turned
back around that's what Obama did and
also a lot of these kid like there was
just a news story about a two-year-old
who's who's alone in court and there's a
judge
talking to him you're like what the [ __ ]
is that well that happened under Obama
to that it has been happening for a long
time like you're saying like the you
know the children a lot of them won't
see their families but the ones that do
what you've seen you've seen the videos
if you're separated from your mom at
nine months and then you see them when
you're 19 months you don't [ __ ] she is
even if you know who they are you you
don't there's videos of kids who don't
know the day for sure there's like
fluctuations and the damage but a
seven-year-old kid who hasn't seen his
parents in a year yeah is irreversibly
there well who's been given [ __ ]
whatever lexapro yeah and then [ __ ]
finger aged yeah like I mean really
here's the thing about here's the thing
about putting human beings in like a
concentration camp situation the people
it's shocking that that has to be a
preface in 29 listen the people who try
to get jobs there are predators you're
setting up a population of people to be
preyed upon and to become victims
because that's who wants those jobs they
want the power they see oh there's kid
jails oh well I'm a [ __ ] pervert and
they go and get a job well and it's like
Abu Ghraib the empowerment that you feel
in these situations are sand they're
secretive yeah so it's like you're gonna
be surrounded by bullheadedness that's
gonna be that makes the reality warped
yeah and then you live in a you work and
these kids live in a place where like
the rules they're just it's different
it's just it's I mean the kids that are
coming out of there are gonna be I mean
you're just creating a giant group of
crazy people they can they're not going
to be able to a lot of our Camila
mentally survive and it's and it's and
really it is what American policy is
which is like solve your quote/unquote
problem immediately do it at by any
means necessary well guess what's gonna
[ __ ] happen I mean in 20 years this
is not going to age well this this [ __ ]
is how you create
these movements of hatred towards us
that is [ __ ] merited and warranted and
then we will sit here because our media
won't give us any context and go man
these [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's like
you you this you damage you damage early
and then later you wonder why people
come to [ __ ] hey grow to hate you and
want revenge upon you and we do that
that is American policy it is like
Pennywise dollar foolish every [ __ ]
decade and has been in forever and it's
all about money I mean putting these
kids in camps it's just so prison you
know the [ __ ] [ __ ] can make money
yeah they're all private prisons but
Trump actually said when he was running
for office
Eisenhower's the model so he told us
right this is the st. concentration camp
this and he and he said I I'm not gonna
let them go at the border I'm gonna fly
them deep into Mexico he said he knew
all this he said all this he said it out
loud we all and no one should be
surprised if you know history but
everyone's acting like this has never
happened before the [ __ ] it hasn't it's
all happened before well it's always
good to end the week on a uplifting
story as we did it yeah we do you feel I
feel good yeah I feel like a winner yep
yep no this this this is this is good
this is this is some good [ __ ] all right
well one second tax base a bookie to me
anyway dollar podcast.com all tours
shows and stuff thank you everybody